Here are the best high-end
products I tested in 2022.
Let's start with face products.
The Nars Light Reflecting
Advanced Skincare foundation
is so lightweight on the skin.
The coverage is on the
light to medium side,
but I definitely think you can build it up
without it getting cakey.
It makes your skin look
really fresh and dewy
without looking oily.
The Haus Labs foundation blends
into the skin seamlessly.
The coverage is on the lighter side
but still buildable.
It has skincare ingredients in it,
and it actually feels like skincare.
It feels like you have
absolutely nothing on your face.
All of my other products
blend on top of this beautifully,
so this foundation is
a 10 out of 10 for me.
This is the Summer
Fridays sheer skin tint.
It's supposed to be
lightweight, hydrating,
and very natural on the skin.
I definitely think it's
all of those things.
The coverage is obviously sheer,
but it evened out my skin nicely.
This is a great everyday skin tint.
I'm not a pot-concealer kind of person,
but I really love this
REM Sweetener concealer.
This concealer looks
thicker than it feels.
I was actually surprised
at how lightweight it felt
when I was blending it out.
And the coverage with this is amazing.
The Kosas Revealer concealer
is so easy to work with
and blends out so quickly.
The coverage is a bit
lighter than medium to me,
but it covers enough.
I also love the Cloud Set setting powder.
It smooths everything
out almost instantly,
and it just gives a
really soft, blurred look.
The One/Size Beauty Cheek
Clapper 3D blush trio
has three different formulas,
a flex cream, a full-impact
matte, and a hypersheen.
These are really pigmented,
and they just look beautiful
and smooth on the skin.
There are just so many
different ways you can use it,
and all the formulas
work together so nicely.
The Made for Shade bronze and sculpt trio
is also very pigmented
and adds a nice bronzy warmth to the skin.
This is the Merit bronze balm,
and it's supposedly the
"easiest bronzer ever."
It's definitely one of
the easiest bronzers
I think I've ever used.
It takes little to no
effort to blend this out,
and it didn't break up the
product I already had on.
The Haus Labs Bio-Blurring
loose setting powder
definitely does blur the
skin and sets your makeup
without making it look dry or cakey.
It's so soft and finely milled,
and it's also talc-free, which is great.
Moving on to eye products.
This is the Danessa
Myricks Beauty Lightwork IV
Transcendence palette.
It has four different formulas:
velvet chromes, which are
color-shifting powders;
pressed chrome flakes,
which are flaky toppers;
glass metallics, which are
super-reflective powders;
and aqua chromes, which are
water-activated duo-chrome pigments.
There is so much going on in this palette,
but all the formulas apply beautifully.
It's extremely pricey, and I
did get some slight fallout,
but the quality is there, and I think
it's so much more versatile than it looks.
Plus it can be used on the face, too.
This is the KVD Dazzle
long-wear eyeshadow stick.
It's supposed to be a
one-and-done type of product,
so you don't need primer.
You just swipe it on and blend.
It really does glide on easily,
and it has so much
glitter and shimmer in it.
It's like a way to do glitter
without any of the mess.
These are the Kaleidos Epiphany
Glow Melt-On eyeliners.
They're all multi-chrome,
so they have these
really cool color shifts.
These are so easy to apply,
and the formula is really smooth.
This MAC MACStack mascara is
super volumizing, which I love.
It gives your lashes an instant lift,
and I have really straight lashes.
I think it makes them look long and full
without looking clumpy.
Next, let's talk about lip products.
The Fenty Skin Plush Puddin'
intensive recovery lip mask
feels so moisturizing
and plush on the lips.
The formula is very thick,
but I personally love that in a lip mask.
My lips were so much
more soft and hydrated
after using this mask consistently.
I'm obsessed with the Summer
Fridays lip butter balms.
The formula is on the
thicker side, but not sticky.
They feel really moisturizing,
and I like how they give
an almost lip-gloss effect.
They all give a pretty
subtle wash of color,
and they have this nice vanilla scent
that's not overpowering.
The Item Beauty Lip Quip
moisturizing lip oil
smells amazing, kind of peachy.
The color is actually
a little more pigmented
than I was expecting for a lip oil,
but I think it's so pretty.
It feels super nourishing,
and it just makes your lips look so juicy.
This is the Hourglass Cosmetics Phantom
volumizing glossy balm.
It's supposed to be a
lip balm, lip plumper,
and a lip gloss all in one product.
They have this really nice cooling effect,
and they do feel like a
super-moisturizing lip balm
but have this high-shine
finish, like a gloss.
It didn't do much for
me in terms of plumping,
but I do love how these
look and feel on the lips.
The Rare Beauty Kind Words
matte lipsticks and lip liners
are the most comfortable
matte lip products.
The lip liner is super smooth.
Even though it's matte,
it doesn't drag or pull on the lips.
Plus it's a twist-up, which I love.
The lipstick is so creamy and pigmented.
You could probably put
this on in one swipe.
This is the Nars Powermatte lipstick.
It has really amazing color payoff.
The texture is so unique.
It's this soft, powdery,
comfortable kind of matte
that actually feels
really nice on the lips,
and it's transfer-proof.
I highly recommend this one.
This is the Fenty Beauty Icon semi-matte
refillable lipstick.
So the case and the actual
lipstick are sold separately,
and then you assemble them together.
The pigment is incredible
and totally full coverage.
It's just a very creamy
formula that feels so smooth
and hydrating on the lips.
The Haus Labs Atomic Shake lip lacquer
is one of those transfer-proof
glossy lipsticks,
so you shake the product
well and then apply it.
The pigment in this really shocked me.
It was so vibrant, it almost looked neon.
I didn't need more than one
layer for full coverage,
and it was so glossy.